♪♪
-A pizza slice
is not a triangle.
It is a sector,
because the short side
is an arc.
[ Laughter ]
I said I've come to terms
with the fact
that I'm never gonna say
"eureka!"
in a moment of discovery.
Then I had to clarify because --
and these are my words --
I said
some eagle-eyed viewers caught
that I had said "eureka"
in a previous "Corrections,"
and then a bunch of you piled on
and said it actually
wouldn't require eagle eyes,
because it would be
something that we heard.
Unless the volume was down
and you were watching
the closed captioning.
Ya burnt.
[ Laughter ]
We said that
based on the regularity
with which he commits crimes,
it would not be surprising
if on the day he announced
he was running for president,
Donald Trump shoplifted a pair
of earrings from Claire's.
We then zoomed in,
and in his hand,
a bunch of you said
that's actually a 20-pack
of earrings from Claire's.
So he didn't just steal one
pair of earrings, he stole 20.
But what if, in the world
we had built,
he paid for 19...
[ Laughter ]
...and then stole one?
Why do you all have to jump
to the worst-case scenario
with this man?
Of whom I'm not a fan!
But this "guilty until proven
innocent" has to stop.
Shame on you.
You guys, a few years back,
Randy Johnson killed a burn.
[ Laughter ]
He killed a bird.
We all saw it.
We all know we were
supposed to feel bad.
We loved it.
He killed a bird.
The bird was, I discovered,'
a mourning dove,
spelled M-O-U-R-N.
I then made the observation
that if a bird
already in mourning
was hit by a baseball
and exploded,
that would be like a hearse
driving off
the side of a cliff.
A lot to unpack here.
[ Laughter ]
Let's begin.
Alright.
I was told by a lot of you
the analogy doesn't work
because a hearse
going off a cliff
would only take the life
of the hearse driver,
who is not in mourning.
He's just working.
[ Laughter ]
Like, he has no...
He's just a guy doing his job.
Like, that's just freight.
[ Laughter ]
Nothing more, nothing less.
He just punched in,
drove that coffin
from there to there,
punched out.
With that said, I'm sure
professional hearse drivers
would tell you you want
to maintain, like, stoicism.
You want to feel --
you want to project sadness.
You don't want to just
be like, "Load 'em up!"
[ Laughter ]
"My third one today!
Must be something going around."
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, lady, your husband
like Night Ranger?
Might blast some tunes."
[ Laughter ]
"On the way to the G-yard."
Also, I was told another error
in that you can't drive off
the side of a cliff.
You can only drive off
the top of a cliff
and then you plummet
down the side.
With that said, if everybody --
anybody ever tells
any of you jackals
they lost a loved one
when their car went over
the side of a cliff,
let it go.
[ Laughter ]
We were talking about doves
and pigeons,
and we talked
about pigeons cooing.
I thought pigeons
and doves sounded the same.
I was told
they're very different.
Here's the sound
of a pigeon.
[ Pigeon cooing ]
Here's the sound of a dove.
[ Dove cooing ]
And here is the sound
of a white-winged dove.
[ "The Edge of 17" plays ]
-♪ Ooh, ooh ooh ♪
[ Laughter ]
Any Nicks fans in the house?
We're coming up on Emmy season,
which means a lot of people
in the biz
are coming down
with Emmy fever.
Emmy fever, it should be noted,
CAN be treated with ivermectin.
[ Laughter ]
A couple of -- couple of squirts
from the old tube.
[ Laughing ]
Hey, I've been making clear
that the Specjackular is not
and has never been
an episode of "Corrections."
It is its own thing.
One might even say you would
categorize it differently.
But then a bunch of you said,
"Hey, if that's the case,
why is it listed as episode 50?"
Shut the [bleep] up.
[ Laughter ]
What are you doing?
Shut the [bleep] up.
[ Scoffs ]
Oh, we asked you guys
to help us
pick our Emmys submission
for "Corrections,"
and it's been pretty resounding.
There are two.
I would say the front-runner
is episode 66.
That's our Christmas episode.
Also, episode 69.
We're gonna put those up.
Let's put those up
on Sea Captain Polls
as our two options.
I'd like you to watch
them both again.
I genuinely mean this,
'cause I think
66 is a lot of fun.
It seems maybe more dependent
on previous episodes.
69 might be a better standalone.
I don't know.
I'm gonna let you guys decide.
But this is a big deal.
Take it seriously because
if everything breaks our way,
the episode you choose
will have the honor
of losing to Carpool Karaoke.
[ Laughter ]
I know -- I think I know
the difference,
which I think works against us.
Any episode of Carpool Karaoke
is good.
Any episode of "Corrections"
is good
if you've watched
every other episode.
[ Laughter ]
We're asking for a lot of time.
I like when someone writes
a comment
that makes it very clear this is
their first "Corrections,"
that they've stumbled upon it,
maybe the algorithm
pushed it their way,
and they say something
that makes it very clear
they haven't watched
this before.
Someone wrote,
"This has to be the worst
studio audience in TV."
[ Laughter ]
Look, I get it -- if you're
watching this cold, you might --
This looks the same way
our show looks,
so you might think,
"Wow, this is just a --
this is just a dead audience."
I get that.
But you don't think
I'd wear it at all?
Like, I'm pretty upbeat
during Correc-- I mean,
if this was
a full audience
making the sounds they've made,
I'd just be like,
"Aw, [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
[ Sniffles ]
Now, there are other people who
think there are too many laughs,
and that maybe
we're sweetening it a little,
like the jackal who wrote,
"Does the staff get paid extra
for laughing at 'Corrections'?"
[ Laughter ]
They do. Per laugh.
I pay them each per laugh.
[ Laughter ]
So it's like $9 that I split
among most everybody.
[ Laughter ]
But Buck just bought
his second yacht.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Got a backup yacht.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sighing ] Having --
I've been having
a little bit of fun
mispronouncing the name
of a famous Greek mathematician.
I've said "Arch-i-meds."
I've said "Archie-meads."
I know, by the way.
I know the correct pronunciation
is Archime--
-Deez nuts!
[ Laughter ]
-Eureka!
Alright, we were talking
about Flaco the owl
and how nobody needs to be
worried about Flaco the owl
not finding food
'cause he eats rats
and he's in Central Park,
and an owl who eats rats
starving in Central Park
would be like a toddler starving
in a chicken nugget factory.
A bunch of you said the nuggets
would be frozen,
so the kids at the factory
would starve.
And then a bunch of you took
the other side of the argument,
my initial position,
that kids in a chicken nugget
factory would be fine.
Including someone
who wrote,
"Nuggets in
a chicken nugget factory
would not all be frozen.
Freezing them is one of
the last steps before shipping.
First, the chicken is ground up
and mixed with chicken skins,
then combined with a beige paste
to make a chicken-flavored goo
that is poured
into nugget-shaped molds.
They are then fried in batter."
I don't know what
that person's job is.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm guessing it's not head
of marketing for Tyson Chicken.
[ Laughter ]
"For the next round
of commercials,
I think we got to really
lean into beige paste."
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of the owl,
I mentioned how one of our
crew members, Kenny Coyle,
has been telling everybody
he could catch the owl.
[ Laughter ]
I said a few lines as Kenny,
and then some people wrote
and said,
"Based on how he's talking,
is Kenny Shoemaker's kid?"
[ Laughter ]
And I want to apologize
for not making this clear.
Almost everyone who works here
is one of Shoemaker's kids.
[ Laughter ]
They just keep coming out
of the woodwork.
[ Laughing ]
And when they do,
they're what Shoemaker
classifies as must-hires.
[ Laughter ]
Don't get me wrong,
he's not happy about it.
The amount...
[ Laughing ]
The amount of times he comes,
he comes into my office
and just plops down
on the couch and is like,
"There's another one
at the page desk."
[ Laughter ]
He's so -- He's so mad
he did 23andMe.
[ Laughter ]
He's so mad,
and it's such a burn on him,
'cause he did it
because none of us believed
he descended
from the Medicis.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
He wanted to prove
he was Italian royalty.
[ Laughter ]
And instead, once a week,
someone from reception calls up
and says, "Mr. Shoemaker,
there's another genetic match."
[ Laughter ]
Someone said
I said people are jealous
of my Mac Tonight toys.
And someone said
they wouldn't be jealous --
they would be envious.
So you're telling me...
someone wouldn't be jealous...
of this?
[ Laughter ]
Every time you think
it can't get [bleep] worse...
[ Laughter ]
A lot of -- We talked about
people dying of old age,
and then someone said, no,
people don't die of old age.
What happens is their body just
breaks down as they get older
and they get more
susceptible to illness.
And then a lot of you said,
"No, no, no,
people can die of old age."
And one person said,
to prove this point,
they said the Queen's
death certificate
said she had died of old age.
But come on.
They weren't going
to put "auto-affix"--
[ Laughing ]
[ Laughter ]
Ah, well.
Eh, I'll do it anyway.
Then we're gonna put
"auto-erotic 'affixiation.'"
-♪ God save the Queen ♪
[ Scattered laughter ]
-[Bleep] blew it, dude.
[ Laughter ]
See me next week.